hey you remember wicked that Broadway
show that took the world by storm by
looking at a popular story and giving it
a new point of view and everybody has
been trying to rip off in one way or
another recently well now we have
Disney's version a one of many but this
is one that actually takes place in Oz -
its Oz the great and powerful and
imagine it take from director Sam Raimi
who mixes imagination and wonder with
awkwardness and a lot of clumsy choices
a magician played by James Franco wants
to make a name for himself by doing
great things but he just can't seem to
get off the ground well one day he
literally gets off the ground with a
balloon gets sucked away into a storm
and wakes up in the Land of Oz of course
comes across some interesting characters
and some interesting baddies and he
tells everyone that he is in fact a
powerful wizard by using his illusion
sense salesmanship he convinces everyone
he can do great things and for the most
part everybody believes him
but soon an evil witch played by Rachel
Weisz tries to use his tricks to her
advantage while also using her sister
played by Mila Kunis by manipulating her
romantic interest in him to fulfill an
evil plot okay so what are the good
things well as you'd imagine especially
being a Sam Raimi film it is very
visually interesting some of these
backgrounds look a little repeated like
we saw this in Tim Burton's Alice in
Wonderland or Laura the Rings but then
you get some really cool scenes like the
opening is done in a different aspect
ratio this is obviously supposed to be
very similar to the trick they did in
the first film where it starts off in
black and white and then it goes to
color not only does this start out in
black and white but it's not in
widescreen and even when it's not in
widescreen they use the 3d effects very
cleverly like when someone shoots fire
out or throws a hat it actually goes
outside the boundaries and it works more
to its advantage when you travel to Oz
and they go to widescreen and you see
how vast and gigantic it can be
sometimes I have to admit it does kind
of capture the spirit of the original
Wizard of Oz there's a wonderful scene
where he comes across this little china
doll and tries to glue her back together
everything about this scene is capped
for lack of a better word magical it's
just a magical wonderful little moment
the music the pacing the acting
effects the effects are unbelievable
here you really feel like this thing is
alive it's a really charming tender
moment that I really wish the rest of
the film was like but sadly it isn't it
just kind of feels like some choices
were made that shouldn't have been made
James Franco can be an unbelievably good
actor but he seems kind of miscast here
I feel like there should have been
someone a little older or a little bit
better at being a fast talker he just
kind of looks like a guy who's trying to
play a con artists not an actual con
artists himself the whole film as you
probably imagine is building up to the
classic liar revealed story and I hate
these stories I think we're all so sick
of it I think we put up with it more if
tons of creative stuff was coming and
yeah there are some really creative
scenes but story wise it goes the route
you think it's gonna go and yeah the
whole time you're watching it you're
thinking huh wasn't this done a lot
better in wicked and speaking of which
let's get to the ultimate blunder in
this movie Mila Kunis as the Wicked
Witch Oh Lord this is a good actress she
can do good stuff but this is completely
the wrong choice it's like having
William Shatner is Hamlet or Leonardo
DiCaprio as the mask just some things
don't go together and you know they're
not gonna go together but you kind of
hope it's like Michael Keaton and Batman
like everyone thought it wasn't gonna
work but maybe it'll play out maybe the
director saw something that nobody else
saw but no the makeup is ridiculous the
voice she has isn't dramatic and it
isn't intimidating it just looks like a
little girl dressing up for Halloween
and screaming I'm the Wicked Witch
believe me on the Wicked Witch it's hard
to watch like really hard to watch and
like I said this is a good actress she
has tons of other work to her credit
this just isn't gonna be one of them the
majority of feedback I hear on this
movie is mostly really negative like
people not only dislike this movie they
hate it they just thought it was the
pits well I think some scenes are I
can't quite go that far
the liar revealed story is painful but
the rest of the set up I thought was
actually kind of clever if given a
little bit more focus and a few
different choices made I think this
could have been actually a really good
story and
right really great film but as is kind
of like the spider-man movies they're
well intended and creative and visually
interesting but they're just kind of
awkward the moments that work are really
great moments the ones that don't are
just kind of uncomfortable I guess I
wasn't expecting that much I mean I
wasn't especially excited for this movie
so maybe there wasn't as big a
disappointment for me I'm still glad I
saw certain scenes I liked some of these
creative characters I like when they're
flying in the bubbles I like when he's
playing the china doll back together I
like some of this imagery but clearly
some of these casting choices should
have been moved around some of the
dialogue could have been a lot more
clever the pacing in some moments could
have been a little tighter which leads
to an obviously good intentioned but
still clumsy movie if you're in the mood
for some good visuals and a couple of
nice scenes I say this isn't that bad
one to check out if you're in the mood
for something that's much more complete
and put together I say you're probably
gonna need a lot more glue